did you guys see the whole twitter thing
with taliban and trump and all that kind
of trending yeah
why don't we start with that since we're
already on this topic here i know we got
a lot of other things to go through uh
just some stories for folks to know
about that we're gonna cover today
is the the elon musk receiving 6.7
billion dollars in compensation in 2020
11 times more than the second highest
paid ceo only fans
grows revenue 553 during pandemic both
tom zenner and g have some comments on
that
uh daniel craig reveals he will not be
giving his kids an inheritance palantir
a controversial interesting company he
decides to buy 50 million dollars in
gold bars what are you doing buying 50
million dollars that's interesting we
will talk about that and a bunch of
other stories that we have here but
let's look at twitter okay let's look at
twitter let's look at twitter so twitter
is apparently
refusing to ban taliban accounts vows to
remain vigilant moderating content this
is a rap the rap story twitter will
allow taliban affiliated accounts to
continue using its platform despite its
policies against glorification of
violence and threats with the taliban
now regaining control over most of
afghanistan again after the afghan
government collapsed this week social
media companies are now forced to
revisit their policies on pro taliban
accounts either try to recruit new
members from around the globe or
spreading disinformation about the
ongoing civil war a prominent taliban
spokesperson
luha mujahid is still active on the site
with over 300 000 followers mujahid was
tweeting as recent as august 17
promoting a press conference unlike its
competitors tiktok and facebook
twitter doesn't have an outright ban on
taliban accounts facebook told cnbc it
will continue to enforce a ban on
taliban accounts that's been in place
for several years and added that it is a
terrorist taliban accounts that's been
in place for uh organization and we have
banned it from our services okay so
that's that part and twitter slammed
after trump is banned but taliban
spokesperson tweets freely uh you know
about the fall of this so what do you
think about this whole position twitter
statement excuse me you know how do you
describe that it's well a lot of layers
here but okay let's talk about the
spokesperson for the taliban all right
so i can't really pronounce his name
effectively but it's
ahid i believe that's who it is and he's
constantly on there
and by the way he's not verified hold on
wait wait
how long how many times did you rehearse
that before you said that you nailed
that on the first try man like seriously
you just got off the plane and you were
like
i hope i was close enough
yeah that was part of my elaborate ruse
to get that name right today flawless
300 000 followers and he's not verified
if you're the person at twitter in
charge of verifying wouldn't you want
the taliban guy not mad at you and you
verify and give him that check mark
right away you know if you watch this if
you peel it back this is a pr campaign
by the taliban
to project themselves as the kinder more
gentler
less of oppressive taliban and it's and
they're using it pretty effectively you
know tick tock has banned them facebook
has banned them instagram obviously has
banned them they they don't have a form
but they have one and look at it like
this how has
banning donald trump hurt twitter it has
not hurt them at all their revenue or
their their stock is up 16 this year so
they haven't suffered anything really
from banning trump they're the ones
being talked about right now you know
people are running to twitter to see
what they're saying and and it's working
i think for the taliban i don't think
you want to underestimate what they're
trying to accomplish here and having
what appears to be a willing accomplice
with twitter to let them do it you know
i give you i give you a story here
that's that's very um
that's very challenging uh uh to to see
what is the right move to make so in
iran
when khomeini was doing his thinking it
was creating momentum he did it with
tapes
simply tapes like cassette tapes right
and through cassette tapes from france
he kept sending it in from paris because
he was in exile in paris and he kept
sending these tapes and everybody slowly
but surely said to jira what khomeini
said did you what comedy said did you
work home and he said so these tapes you
burn them and you give them to other
people right
and sean knew this was happening and
shah's concern in iran was more the
two-day party which is a communist party
than khomeini and as people said listen
you got to put a stop to this and there
was a part of shah that said this guy's
never going to have the kind of power to
come and take over
uh iran and iran was becoming the top
five empire worldwide everybody's
looking at him he's negotiating with all
the bigger guys 25-year contract he
strikes with france with uk with us with
you know germany all these guys so he's
doing he's doing the right things
and then all of a sudden one of his
military guys says look i'm gonna say
this to you one last time we got to take
this guy out we gotta figure he knew
where he was they could get to him they
could do something to him sure to stop
all of this madness he says he's not
gonna create that kind of momentum huh
you have two different advisors one
advisor saying don't worry about it it's
not going to create that kind of
momentum another group is saying what
we've got to take this guy out what ends
up happening
we know what ends up happening the
regime comes takes over revolution nine
million people revolt over a message
because khomeini kept saying we're going
to give you free food we're going to
give you free housing we're going to
give you free all this stuff and then
iran changes you know and then now you
know what the half a million people die
war iran's you know iraq all that mess
i think
the the hardest part like the guy i was
talking to yesterday the communistic
professor right you're like do you allow
a guy like that to teach
is that the biggest threat do you allow
somebody like this to be on twitter
do you allow somebody like this to
recruit younger people who haven't yet
shaped their level of thinking think
about you at 16 years old 17 years old
think about what moved us at 16 17 18
years old how easy easy it was to us for
us to be manipulated by somebody right
some of us are stronger than others but
to allow people like this to be on
twitter i mean what are you doing
i actually i i think you should but i
you have to make sure if you're going to
allow him to be on twitter you have to
allow somebody else to be you
well fine trump anybody i've been kicked
off twitter four times but here's the
four times here's the question the
taliban's still on there here's a
question though i don't know about that
and here's why
because to me
um uh uh go to your kids let's just say
you got kids you're 45 years old you got
two kids okay gerard uh herron michaels
okay you got two kids
are you okay with your kids kicking it
with anybody
uh
yeah i think so um you sure i i don't
have kids it's hard for me to say okay
are you okay with yourself it's
absolutely not i'm not because i'm i'm
actually opposed to him hanging out with
some of his friends you know i've
identified people that i don't want him
being around why not though because bad
judgment that other person does stupid
things you could be involved in it at
what age are you comfortable first of
all you don't have a choice after at
certain age yeah right what age are you
like i can't do nothing about it you
know what i i hope i'll always have the
relationship where i'll have that sway
with them and i know i will but you know
at the age of 21 or 20 or something when
you don't have day-to-day contact or
whatever you're not paying everything
someone's going to be able to go yeah
sure
man if you've raised your kids right
what if your kid can be the positive
influence in that other kid that you
don't like that's not my responsibility
i would i would rather protect him from
something that is not his fault they
can't translate him from ideas no but
that's a why it's a wide opening by the
way by the way i agree
okay here's a here's a random question
for you at what age did you see pot uh
12. okay at what is your juicy pot
maybe 15 because i grew up in the stone
ages okay yeah so i'm the same age 12
13. and what age did you see cocaine
uh 14
18. eighteen you saw cocaine right right
when i get started okay at what age uh
did you
see a you know a person getting freaking
trashed hammered dragged you know like
absolutely lost their minds because how
drunk they were 14 okay yeah late teens
lay teens for some people may be
different because it could be your
parent right because some people tell
you i'm two years old that's how you
know my mom or my dad but i get what
you're saying here but
here's my point to you the point i'm
trying to make to use eventually you're
going to see it yeah how old were you
the first time you saw somebody pull a
gun how old were you first time you saw
a stabbing or have you seen somebody die
have you seen some of that things are
going to happen
but to allow somebody
that is purely about violence gerard
this is not like an opposing idea yeah
there's a big difference between ideas
so so to what do you call it to the shah
he was more worried about the idea of
communism and he was less he was less
worried about a guy that wanted to
revolt and absolutely he killed every
one of his generals sure the khomeini
killed every one of his generals so
which messaging do you have to be more
worried about when you're running a
nation i i i need to look i think we
should be ever vigilant and i'm no fan
of the taliban but i also remember the
ira were a terrorist group and now
they're a legitimate political party as
well the ira you know with sin feign are
a legitimate political party and they
were terrorists they absolutely were and
they were murdering terrorists but to
them they were freedom fighters fighting
an oppressive regime uh i'm not pro
taliban and i find i find this world
we're living in so crazy that the week
started with the department of homeland
security essentially describing me as a
terror threat and then i'm listening to
the taliban spokesman what do you mean
describing you well the department of
homeland security
put out a terror threat who who is uh
who is a high terrorist people who are
are skeptical of coveted measures people
who uh
love america and people who uh are
use the word patriotic and people who um
uh have deference for the 9 11 holiday
those are all
they was on lester holt oh so i mean did
you see that yeah yeah i'm so they they
basically described me and i'm like holy
crap
yeah i'm like what and then that's on
nbc nightly news that's how my week
begins now my week is ending with me
listening to the taliban spokesman
person give american companies a lecture
on free speech and be right about it and
i'm like wait so we started with the
department of homeland security and it
ends with taliban like whoa what message
what what what are you
okay not like saying is there something
for you to say i don't think that's cool
to allow i think
i think the market of ideas i believe in
humanity i believe in the invisible hand
i think that we don't need laws telling
people not to block the the exit if
there's a fire because there's a fire
people will leave the exit right i i
think that the way you stamp out
extremism is by shining a light on it i
think that you you you don't have to
amplify one voice or another extremism
to me is cancer you talking about
homeani i would have i would have said
take him out i would have said one hunt
and this is the problem i have with with
my libertarian friends and this is where
they get after me i don't believe in the
non-aggression principle i don't i think
counter punching all the time is stupid
i think some things you have to get in
front of and you can save a lot of
people okay the the
you cannot negotiate a part of that
that's contradictory though isn't it
based on what you're saying because
if that's what you're saying isn't it
isn't it good to get ahead of something
like this
isn't it good to get ahead let's just
say this guy that's got 300 000
followers he converts one guy that's
more aspirational than anybody else and
he becomes the next guy that costs a
million lives
but just to complete that thought that's
a great point but you said it yourself
homany was
banned and that made him more popular he
went underground this isn't this
magga isn't gone it's underground
it's not just because
twitter exists because frankly
republicans and conservatives fell
asleep at the wheel and they didn't
compete in tech there's no question and
they didn't compete in education the
fact that that there's nothing there's
no place for these folks to go
it's not the left's fault the left out
competed and they out innovated it's the
wright's fault i don't think that's
right so hey i would say this don't
underestimate the taliban this is pure
propaganda for them and and i'm not so
worried about one some an average person
falling for this i'm worried about
mainstream media buying into this crap
and then continuing the narrative that
the taliban has changed and these guys
are smart and let's also remember one
thing they're not a government all right
they are not a government they are
extremists radical muslims that have
taken over a country u.s government is
right now negotiating with the taliban
to let the troops be released u.s is
negotiating with the taliban right now
to allow the uh the translators to be
released i mean u.s is negotiating right
now directly with the taliban yesterday
won the press conferences they asked the
general hey
it sounds like you're negotiating with
the taliban and you're waiting on
taliban to allow you to get the troops
to get out is that true and did you see
what the guy said what it's like uh
uh
jenner milly and jen
you guys gonna see that yeah it was the
most awkward moment yeah like that's
what's happening right now so yeah i
don't know i think
um i i think i'm i'm a part of you got
to get ahead of it before it becomes a
bigger problem i'm more from the mindset
of only the paranoid survive and i think
america is not paranoid enough right now
i think america is being a little bit
too
uh
trusting and casual and comfortable and
the last time we were like that and
events happen
on 9 11. and i think people have to be a
little bit more paranoid today with
events that are taking place i i that's
that's my mindset so when you hear
something like this let's just let him
on there on twitter what more
but think about it but twitter
everybody's talking about twitter every
single day yeah i mean this is they're
probably going to let it ride until they
pull in isis and start showing
decapitations or something so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]